Farmers.
They have an interest in sustainability,...
...but what's been lacking historically for growers...
...is having the data and the tools that they need...
...to be able to do that well.
And that's the reason we're so excited to work with farmers,...
...to give them the guidance that will help them succeed.
I'm Tyler.
I'm Adam.
And we're the co-founders of Agrology.
We started Agrology in 2019.
We've been kicking around the idea...
...of how do we use a lot of different sensors...
...and machine learning and sensor fusion...
...to deliver predictive insights to our growers...
...to thrive in a changing climate.
Traditionally, growers, they try to use predictions themselves,...
...but they can't be on every inch of every farm every day.